Hey everyone, how you doing? I'm excited to introduce you with our new feature
It's the custom model plugin architecture and in this demo. I will with you in the live
We'll go through it. Okay. So first and first we start on this page
please take a look on all these rules and disclaimers they are important and
Okay, let me start with
Opening my virtual machine. I will do everything with you
I'll take a pause while it's loading
Okay, so I will do it first. Just clear my terminal
Okay, I cleared it and
Let's go through the guide first. I will follow this
flow right here and
Yeah, let's go to the update and restart page
It's changed a little bit so you can also please take a look especially on the important nodes
but first thing first, I need to go to my
British folder
This is it. I have a little bit different naming than you but still I have this CD with the bridge folder
I will run these commands
Okay
Inside and here I can do get pulled
Okay, you see I have the error of a good pull and I have in the guide
There is specific information how to make it work. So get reset hard and then get pulled
Okay, cool. So I pulled all the changes from my remote repository
and then I need to
update my
Python dependencies, so I am just running the commands from the script and I will take a pause until it's done
Okay, it's done. So I clear my terminal what's next? Okay. Now it's time to experiment with the models
I go back to our main guide and also I will run here this
pseudo update command
Okay, and I will come back when it's done
Okay, it's all done all updated. And now I will I just want to play with my
Yeah, I just want to add
Let's pick up couple features so I want to pick up the temperature
and humidity, for example
play with this feature as you want and yeah, let me use the
Lex feature just last two hours. I think my model won't be that good. But let's try so I save this features
Why?
All right. Okay, it's done here and
What is my next step now? I need to run my minor
Okay, so I will use the option number three
Number three. I don't want to update my training
Data set timing and yes, I want to create a new folder. Yes here
I will use the folder name from example custom test
Creating this folder. So what's going on behind the scenes? There is
New folder names artifacts and the custom test model custom test folder created
And inside of this is going to be the training data set
There's some metadata in JSON format as well as template of call up not to book. Okay, it's created
Let's let's have a look
I'm going to change directory to artifacts folder
Change directory to custom model folder that I just created
okay, it's
Everything is here. So
Then I need to create the zip archive of this folder. I will go one level above
So as you can see here, I'm inside artifacts folder, right and I will run this command zip
Create the zip archive and it's creating the zipper archive out of the custom test
folder that just was created and
I want to know let me show you so you can see there. There is a new zipper kind file
Let's know the file the path of this zip archive and we need to download it locally on my laptop
so I'm downloaded it from virtual machine to my
laptop, okay, it's nice
Don't it doesn't want to work. So I restart my virtual machine to make the download file option available
price
clear terminal
Okay, let me
Okay, I am going one more time inside artifacts
Here I want to know the real path of the zipper kind
Done. This is my real path and I just put it in download
Okay, download started. I will come back when it's done
Okay, I have my zipper kind
Downloaded locally. Here is the
folder
Did it yes, okay here it is so you can see here it was downloaded just now. What are my next steps?
Okay, now we go to the call up let's go open the call up
So we need to open the starting page of the Google call up. It's the call up research Google com
I click upload here and I will I will choose
this custom train
Call up file
Think about this call up file as a template. It's just a template. So yeah, let's first run these commands and
As well as these two example is that they are just examples you can play with
other architectures who are not really stick to them his gradient boosting progress we are not really stick to the
Basic neural net here. You can use the LSTM RNN all other types. Just be sure as it mentioned
Previously that it should be regressors models. Okay. Let me take a pause here until when it's done
Okay, so it's all done. We need now according to the base markdown we need to restart our call up session
And let me also as well according to our guide
Change the call up
run type change run type type to the TPU and
Yes, okay and save here
Okay, so we can see the here that the connection is happens while it happens
We can go to our files on the left and create the folder a new folder
custom and
Inside this folder. I will just drop our training data set and Jason made the data
Okay, and
Okay, everything's inside. Let's run this first cell and we also need to update
Copy path here and I need to paste it here
Okay, let's run this command and it will take a second. Yeah, we can see our data set got
Uploaded let's take a look on the data set
We can see here all the temperature and humidity features that I chose
Previously are here our hours and dates features our lag feature
So please don't make any changes inside the call up with the data set itself
All the changes if you want to pick up or drop any features or rename it
Everything happens inside terminal right here
Okay, what's next?
Let me you know, so these two models are just as examples. They are just examples. I will create my own
Model right now with the code and I will show you that you can use the whole flexibility of the call up
Let me take a pause here. Well, I'm developing my new
custom really custom model
Okay, let's continue. So as we can see here, I just created some basic very basic
Linear regression rich model
So it the performance is not that great, but I don't care about it right now
So it's your job to play with the model types and make the model
as best as you can so but important note is that
As you can see here
I added some metrics that I can really where I can really understand how my model is will be
Will perform in production when it's good deployed and also there are some visuals I added
So if you can if you want you can take a pause and here it is my code
But the important part right here is how to save the model. So for the
Skill earn models you need to use the drop leap function for neural nets. You will need to use the
Save function from them from TensorFlow. So as you can see here on the left
My model custom drop leap got dumped. So essentially the weights of the model
Got created so I will download these weights to my local laptop one more time. So in the download folder, there is
This job leap extension model and let's go to our guide
To do we trained we saved
okay, we didn't edit any feature columns, so it's okay and
We download the train model from the call up and let's upload it back to power virtual machine how to do it
Let's clear
We need to click upload file and choose this job leap file from my download folder
Upload files case got uploaded
One caveat that is what uploaded to our home directory
So I will go to my home directory name CD and as you can see here
no path, so
Here it is my model custom job leap
Model the saved model and I need to move this model to our artifacts folder that I showed you
Previously and I can run at this command. I will do some slight change because my path is
Real a little bit different from yours. But as far as I remember you can just run this command
Let me take a pause here and
I will change this comment for now. So I run this comment and V stands for move. I moved our
My model to the artifacts folder. Let me show you how it looks like
this
list to be preach
List I go back to the artifacts directory
list and
I go back to our custom test folder and this one more time as you can see here
Now we have our model custom job leap file
In the virtual machine. How cool is that? So now you really can rerun your model. So
The model got saved in the virtual machine and we need to run it and make it run 24-7, right?
for this reason
Let me clear the terminal output
I already have one minor running but I didn't really had to
Stop it to experiment
It was keep running, but let me show you that I have my running T nooks
attached terminal
Okay, as you can see here my minor is working and making some predictions
But I want to change this model since it wasn't performed. Well, so what I'm doing here
I press control X. Sorry control control C
You can see I'm stopping my minor. I'm stopping the script
And let's clear the terminal and I am inside my beat bridge folder and I did all these changes
Let me show you that so look on the teammates as a container
It's the container that runs the script the script that you tell it to run
So I did all the changes externally and after I stopped my previous minor
This Timo's container took all the changes. So it's understand the changes were done. So let me show you
Let's go to the artifacts folder. I will just show you that you can see here our custom test folder
In our job leap file. So let's just
Restart the minor running this command click run. Okay
Okay, I need to go one level two level of buffs to them
Beat bridge you see now I'm on the level of the beat which folder and let's run it one more time
Okay, I will choose the option number three. I
Don't want to update anything and I don't want to create a new folder
I press no here and I need to enter the
folder name custom
Sorry, what name I used I used custom test custom test custom test
So this is the name of the folder of our model inside the artifacts
custom test
Okay, so it was identified. So this model was identified
These are good news and it asking us do I want to deploy this model or no if in this folder would be
Several models for example, I create one more
I don't know linear regression or decision trees or other models and I will drop them as well in
In our artifacts folder in the custom test folder there
You will have a choice here which model to run, but I want to
Deploy the model I created
Okay, I click run and here we will see the success
logs right now
Okay. Yeah, we can see success that this model got deployed really and after a couple minutes. I will show you
That this model is really making the predictions in the real time. Yeah, I will take a pause for a couple minutes
Okay, so a couple minutes past and 10 40 my miner made a prediction
We can see here that the validator asked it to make a prediction six hours in the future for
440 and we can see here what our miner or what our model used as the input
So for example model input role right here is the JSON format file. You can copy it
You can copy it and for example go
JSON viewer and let's paste it and
These all inputs that our miner in real time used to make a prediction. These are weather forecasting
Okay. So these are good news one thing to mention that
your miner will
Update here in the plot after six hours. So when validator actually will receive the real
Demand data and can make the evaluation for example, you can track this model. I will I will leave it as it is
This is my mind minor number four
I use the previously cart model and now I switched to my custom collapse tile model
So it will it will make different predictions
After six hours also, for example, I have other minor minor 106 and
This one is trying and also my custom call up style model. But this one I spent some time making it so it
Performed much more better. So I had the R square on validation around like point eight or point nine
for example for here for
Model that I just deployed my R square R square was point three. So it's more than just a random guess
Okay, I think this is mostly it so
I hope that you will enjoy just jump in the play and
Experiment and yeah, I hope that you watch this video on the double speed. Okay, this is it from my side
Yeah, reach out if you have any questions
please send the screenshots of the bug fixes and
We also will be happy if you provide us with feedback. Okay. Bye bite and have a good day
Let the hungry day let the hungry game starts. Okay. Goodbye